evening all I'm with my good friend
Chris known as chess explains so we have
again 10 hi Chris yeah I Tryphon game 10
33 games here to go right so yeah um
this is really getting on in its final
stages yeah so any mistake might might
prove fatal here yeah so so and I'm
playing white kicks off with e 4 and we
saw the Sicilian defense chosen again by
boris and yeah and I was in midair I I
had predicted the Queens gambit declined
today so oh yes I was oh yeah my
prediction came right before yes I
predicted evil deny yes ok ok so a night
of free a look uncool canal spectacular
move creating loads of excitement now
just just joking so you didn't go into
them this is Federico vindication and
this is the anti sveshnikov but should
be five the Rosalie mo system and he's
fresh the cove yeah one of those lines
for y term avoids hazardous line hmm
what's own idea three years owners an
option if you want to avoid especially
cop hmm and yeah it's an interesting
choice and I think a pretty yeah a bit
of a fighting choice so in comparison
with with deform you because usually you
don't have so those really long
theoretical lines in this opening but
there should be five it's more awesome
yeah often at least it depends on what
like place now but very often it is kind
of a maneuvering game where you have
lots of pieces on the board and tried to
play a long complicated game so I was
pretty young pretty excited here to
maybe look forward to a long game um so
I'm the main issue now is what what's
black players got the choice of mostly
three moves g6
x + E 61 time he went ecigs yep and I
think I'm the difference it's mostly a
matter of taste maybe g6 is the most
solid move but it's hard to tell it's
really a bit of bit of a the taste thing
here what what you like more um and know
what has some quite some principle
choice you can take on c6 what what
island plate or you can try to yeah
developed further with the ideas of
getting on center with c3 and c4 and so
white could also castle here or place
III but he took immediate loans his
successor ensures that black really get
this double points if it white wood
castle luck would go on a g7 which is
another possibility of course hawai
that's not a bad move castles yeah it's
just different because now if you would
take on c6 Blackwood just recapture the
night you know and it would make so much
sense to do this so he immediately took
on on c6 and then followed it up with B
3 B Tech c3 and then be three it doesn't
make any sense I capture the other why
does it here because black stay full
control if you're done Finch it would
make more sense because it's kind of
because the bishop would be on d4 but
here it makes less sense to capture like
this doesn't that yeah it kind of loses
the tempo in a way because you would
need to play me five later at like you
cannot really positionally allow wide to
play e5 himself on the long run you
don't want this kind of pointy end so it
would lose time BTW xe6 is also young
natural in terms of controlling the
center and yeah now wide again has a
choice you can play quite number of
moves i think castles d3 is also
possible but b3s is quite interesting
it's all about the 'if is putting more
pressure on e5 is sort of taking my
defender of
five and it's like overprotecting e5 no
yeah yeah it's a bit quite usually in
this in this line at some point place
are you 45 and he is sort of um yeah
prepare for the old protection of this
corn yeah to have its own IC centralized
you know and what leg would like to do
here and this is make the next move
really remarkable what likes an idea
formation here's g6e five and most
probably even f5 if you if you get the
time yes just terribly slow yes I had an
unfortunate game in Gibraltar once where
the opponent did get a really good sense
to the two bishops and a family was this
better as a feed a monster he ground me
down it was an interesting game but it
was a bit of an unfortunate game for me
it showed that you know you really got
to know what you're doing with this this
system otherwise you can be applied as
why it's not as technically sharp as
normal Sicilians it's like a real soft
I'm names of engine ideas um yeah it's
it's very much like in Dominion what
with reversed colors some ideas are are
quite similar but whitis yeah in a way
come a bit more time game because he's
got Itoh in one move and black hasn't
even moved the Jeep on yet but this sir
of course to his advantage g5 has a move
on b3 that black doesn't really want to
play he can play this but it's very
committal as putting a pawn on d5 who
beacon c5 really enormously kind of
lagging the names of Indian but were
white would have a couple of extra moves
yeah and what you would like to do is G
685 this kind of setup but if you would
go d six now through just a show then y
term would most largely play a 45 and
prevent e65 from black rights keep it
pushing now exactly you want to sort of
kill this vicious the Titans attached to
it yeah you can't yeah it is a pending
fool sometimes you actually can lower
this and which I'm thinking at the
moment mmm-hmm maybe here you cannot
take on your five but it should just to
show 95 it so it's sometimes funny 95 24
you should be too we should be too yeah
all right we three Queen takes Knight c3
ah cream truck now you're threatening
right before but black has got Bishop a
six and you can also escape on on this
route a 3-2 a 60 this trick is not
working well just just imagine this kind
of position slightly differently than
the Queen project not sure about that
wish me success route be one here Quinn
goes here yeah winner free and you're
hitting f7 and c6 that looks dangerous
yeah yeah yeahs me maybe this this is
this is maybe walking after all what
could be so let's let's check Wiggly
instead of Bishop a sex queen a three
immediately which would be the
alternative hmm then then also Queen a
three yeah maybe what we are looking at
here is just a theoretical line and we
are just reinventing it not quite sure
okay but just to show what what leg
would like to do is to play d6 and you
find a few sort of getting the center
and what what gaffer no played much
might be the move that i'm not sure but
this might put be three out of business
completely mmm lady 5v5 which is not a
novelty I looked it up briefly in the
database have been two or three games
and my database with this move but that
was off I don't know i think one
international master and 22
pretty much unknown players I'm not
quite sure about being in just to those
players i don't remember the names but
they weren't on top level grandmasters
and the thing is what what what what
what can do i do know and he more or
less needs to check on e5 everything
else black will get his desired set up
here six and maybe even f5 you know and
this looks very aggressive so what kind
of why do we cannot play deform and it's
um yeah so it's it's somewhat summer
problematic so I think you need to take
really and yeah now we get this sequence
which happens in the game but and queen
a7 almost was played in Game what about
Queen this diagonals I'll no Queen f6
you just play Bishop b2 padmi you just
protects him as that's not nice that's
loss for black is the air you can cuz
DJ's it's 93 enter yeah you can repeat
it retreat into all right levels at the
same track yep exactly so Queenie seven
either to try and get him briefly a qui
g5 cross my mind but it's just entirely
unnecessary to to think about this
evening yeah because Queenie 7s sir just
perfectly fine and not quite sure that
this makes much sense anyway Queenie
seven is just it's just a good move um
yeah now why doesn't have much outs then
we should be to what what should play on
black just threatens f6 or g6 and
getting at the porn on only four and of
course if I've the night is just hanging
yeah so it's a bit similar to those some
kind of motives and let's say the the
Rue La Paz exchange or other lines where
white captured and took a pawn so black
has this counter play on the Elan to to
get it back and now g6 yep yeah men too
sir this is really off 494 us also the
only sensible move
you couldn't take on c6 which sure maybe
should you should look at briefly not
because of Queenie for um but of 27 just
doing tonight ow Quincy 7 yes oh there
has nursing yeah Whitney for Queenie to
is not not really clear it's not bad for
black but it's not like winning
instantly but this this is winning in
assembly so it's it's all force really
and they played this rather quickly so
go font played all this pretty much
instantly so which is really among
markable that she had some some really
new idea hooked up again this rather
rare be free line yeah he couldn't
expect this at all and well I'm not also
played them rather quickly because
simply there are no other moves um on so
here d5 was played by if Queen sides
this is this worse this negative 90 free
yeah this is a bit risky maybe even
because what no first and foremost gets
into castle your castle and rookie one
and then you well you feel better
developed and maybe this can get ugly
yeah I mean them to King on the farm so
you want exchange of Queens as well so
yeah need to get rid of the Queens and
also spoiler White's castling rights you
enter gets to do this with his mercy a
place just the deep Wang album she
played d 625 now defaults or 3d porn was
that stops the use of nike free now for
the check so exactly and it's not very
nice to play king f1 maybe even bishop a
six-armed possibly or now actually
bishop they are free this this wouldn't
be good my anger shebesh streets i think
blunders and every every one free yeah
yeah but you can just develop normally
and ask white what is the king doing on
f1 yeah um because black has pretty easy
development the thing is that this pawn
on d4
confirmation c 5 t fall and it looks a
bit a bit weakened and at first because
he also on gas sort of like the night on
c4 which is very nicely placed at least
you know it it looks nice yeah but not
sure that it's doing so much but it
looks like but the problem is the bishop
on b2 which is just looking at this d4
pawn and still nothing yeah and what
it's actually not yeah he lay he he
doesn't mind getting rid of the Queen so
with Queens off he's got a little bit
more time to sort of repair this Bishop
position yeah so they could get rid of
the Queen's now yeah and gap and this is
really remarkable piece of opening
preparation because of course this was
prepared on in the line here bye bye
girl font which is so uncommon and
basically I think this is more or less
if the white doesn't come up with
anything great which I don't see then
this basically maybe refutes this be 39
now black has no problems at all yeah
and it's really debatable on if maybe
black and do something but on during
this broadcast and also in the press
conference what play are some are we're
pretty sure that it sits around equal so
its own it's out for y2 to make any
progress in terms of attacking those we
can pawns and decide from that the
structure is very rigid the green side
is completely frozen there are not no
apparent ways to make progress then the
King side is completely symmetrical so
it's really difficult to make any
progress yeah yeah against the good
defense yeah so like just developed the
white this definitely doesn't want to
say like this that will give the be foul
he but he doesn't want to move the night
he just supports the night with the home
yeah yeah you need to get your night on
p1 to someplace so it's it's pretty
pretty logically I think Knight f6
Yahoo's like basically can complete
their development so nice square for the
month at d5 yeah t5 before potential of
squares to to go to and so night busy to
was pride which it's it looks optically
as though it's a pretty position I
fought so black castle queenside
actually I think he might be able to
just cancel King side as well but maybe
the kids kind of useful on c82 yeah yeah
i think so i think blonde castle is a
good idea because you can exactly what
you're showing your queen looking to be
seven or so maybe at some point you to
help protect those pawns yeah and it
also very quickly gift support to to the
d4 pawn which ensures your bed um why it
won't be able to play c3 will ya because
c3 is smooth that why it might my play
if he would be able to false black to
take on c3 but now if i would go see
three black can just just stay and keep
this pawn so what case it's just a
position which is very rigid and well
it's difficult to make any progress i
think i'll try to improve this is a bit
gender also yeah make some use of the
other line so look hg1 hook hu1 yep and
it's all pretty pretty logical you
should be seven flags in the ruined King
everyone young and King f1 making use of
this rope yes and what can why do we can
try to yeah maybe a check c5 on
and this is what what we sheetrock to do
but black always has this couch idea 95
to be four yes and this just this is
what happened in the game Brooke h3h and
yeah he and the broadcaster it was a
briefly discussed what would happen if
white will take on e6 ah yeah it's just
just useful to know these kind of ideas
um but its its own yeah sort of a
fortress kind of kind of move just sort
of remembering the last game and they
both said in the press conference you
can work and play this to ensure draw
but it's not the kind of movie they can
play ball win it's actually buried this
position actually would be very dry but
it's a it's a but it's completely
unnecessary to play it this way with
white you certainly cannot do anything a
constructive here the way the reason
because it is quite georgeous that it's
very hard to open up the position at all
for the books yes the Roses magazine
yeah amazing light vector it makes no
sense to do the zone and risk anything
because white zone you cannot win it's
impossible for him to to to win this
game even if you would will upon it
doesn't really want to like e6 it's not
a pawn you want to take so after all
this idea doesn't make much sense in
terms of playing for when you so I
played Bishop e3 trying to make turn
something off for the c5 weakness but
black has this science a 95 mm and um
yeah basically that's it good so night
before it doesn't good night for a
moment an attack on c5 but that's
parable thankfully for black well he's
got night before word sufficient it
blocks the attack
and at times c2 as well yeah this is the
problem this item before it's really a
yeah somewhat somewhat annoying piece
you always have this pressure on c2 and
Dwight cannot really tolerate this night
for for a long time then you first of
all he protected c2 with rock issue
which also enabled similar to double yes
yeah at this position here it's quite
interesting because I didn't really
expect this next move but it's really it
is played to to sort of clarify the
position to learn to draw really um so
will now get from took on c4 yes and
yeah okay this is just in order to as I
said sure I trade this down to two to
draw neck wasn't forced to do this you
could also play some other neutral mood
but it's not like you can play for
winning with this like women with h 6 or
whatever you could play I'm just
suggesting slightly useful move that
doesn't spoil anything yeah it was not
necessary but okay it's obvious that at
this station he's not really concerned
with the drawing with black shell one
certainly contact with this because then
they free looks pretty strong doesn't
that just live right slicing yeah this
this might be might be an issue with
whites pieces you somewhat uncoordinated
at the moment see also add this
optically pretty night on if hobbit it
off young offsider pretty quickly with
f5 yes so we must must must be careful
with opening up to position too much
then move like f5 would to get the
nitrogene three where would have exactly
no square like h1 you've got a square
but when the this is just terrible so
it's a this is also why I am fishing
outrigger if I'd this position yeah you
can't convert it either because if not I
sensors out
that just takes and you don't want to go
to g3 which is really silly after move
like g6 um your night has absolutely
nothing you know maybe rookie one year
but King b7 it's just a trust okay these
scissors yes King d7 but it's just a
stupid idea to get the nitrogene 3 I
guess we'll an eye to going now as well
yeah yeah okay so he's very special
times before to be able to play Knight
d2 Thanks yeah um yeah like needs a
white needs to be content yet but am i
joking a nice little fact yes he takes
before horse um well if F takes e4 gives
Y a move to play Bishop 85 or something
yeah taking the rock yeah this is now
this is very nice for white yeah you
know don't be very unpleasant because
they'll be a very nasty penman if so
yeah it's listening this might be
winning already my rook here is nasty
and black cannot move anything and white
is just a pawn up yeah in essence the
three against two yeah so he took on
before it offered a raw actually she
digs before Mercer with a draw offer but
I don't declined some I thought that
maybe he hasn't learned something here
yeah but he pretty much came to realize
that it is not so much there were so I
bishop b6 now um yeah it's an what can
you say it's just nothing Jake's on yet
and I be 32 karoxa 5 and black just
played this hmm and now it's a really a
blocked our position I free looks as
though it could be dangerous e5 but here
they actually agreed a draw and I did
check with engine after just to reassure
myself black has no issues so let's say
okay this is the final position where
they great a draw but it takes takes i
think the Kings shows its you
for here with King rb6 thinking be sex
and if rook a5 is it there's a technical
move that black can play here I don't
know if you've seen this analysis before
but blow out a six maybe have yeah so
just to allow that pony addresses so
business exec this is so this looks like
the exactly more and then Bishop b4 and
you can park the bishop now on c3 and
you've got that very dangerous a porn so
this is this and you're also pointing at
a one for a moment so this would be
quite dangerous for white if he went in
for this I'm not not here sorry he would
have to move the King if there but black
black will be doing whelks that a pool I
think in this position yeah why it's
extra pony and disposition is c2 which
is pretty much useless yeah so this is a
very dangerous maybe because the CBC's
the c3 Bishop / controls the promotion
square already and this can get ugly
quickly yeah yeah that's a good
expression yeah maybe quit right so I
just thought those a bit of dangerous
for I mean and people weren't commenting
as usual if you check that yeah it's no
problem if black has the resources like
a six there's no problem again just
sucking the porn if he does try and hold
on to the porn he might be in trouble
with with King b6 like this I mean there
might be check and then check might be
dangerous you don't want all that that's
you don't to get into that because then
you know root b subunit yeah this miss
this might be I'd be annoying so maybe
whatever day success one idea yeah I
also sought just rocks EH and should be
should be ok as well shouldn't zi8
that's a reason just sort of threatening
a six if white plays check now would be
five chick maybe just King a six but
is a bit awkward you really don't want
to do this you change the sort of tied
up now York introduced to drive on baby
you can go up c6 to be 6 and whatnot see
fathomless check mo now this is this is
annoying so maybe a 6 a-6 is maybe just
better you know you're right you're
right so it's better to to UM to play
this threatening King b6 enter yep this
is better so what what what what what do
we learn about the scam that that black
was really a girl found was really
charity well prepared for this rare line
yeah 3 he was and he sort of yeah took
away this white game with a lot much
effort hmm and um yeah what can you do
it it's not not motor sparkling game but
very very important just just for the
standings as Arnold head in these
remaining three games three white games
and now one white game was sort of
drifted away without any future yeah
huge chances to to do something yeah
yeah it went down to two games two games
left so it's a complete mini match now
two games so we just quickly just over
you in summary the game so it was a
Cecilia anti Sicilian reznikov so
doubled pawns and a very quick pawn
sacrifice from black hair which kind of
led to the Queen's coming off quickly
unfortunately for the spectators because
of this D 5 D for preventing any nighty
freeze once the Queens came off black
resourcefully canceled queen site to let
his King assist if needed in the
protection of the porns which as we saw
in some of the variations became
evidence as very useful black was able
to resourcefully defend see fight which
is only issue in the position by this
night before which is also a pain for
white now white spawns became doubled as
well the white knight couldn't go to g3
that will be
asking for trouble so instead we got
more exchanges here more simplification
we've still the issue of c-5 now been
transformed into this a free break which
doesn't seem to be anything much if
black plays accurately so okay that was
game 10 in a nutshell um right I hope
everyone on YouTube got something out
that it's just securing a draw at very
high level of chess maybe it's account
it's something we can use as black
against if we play this reznikoff in
someone places an interesting way of
equalizing with black maybe yeah the c5
mother I think has so it I don't didn't
put much time at this but it looks like
a very very disciplined for black and
named Warlow on yeah with somewhat
somewhat confused why players who wanted
to play this be three line it's a it's a
sideline but it's nice to have fun such
an early new move from to play and sort
of yeah as she was the one to he wanted
to play a surprise with b3 and then you
get this five instantly so it's really
am sort of moral victory for her girl
from this game so yeah we can be curious
just two games left I think those two
games will be played on saturday and
monday and after this maybe try breaks
yeah so we're getting close to two
tiebreaks yeah okay it's pretty hot here
in the UK it's hot in Germany as well
elements but it's very very hot it's one
of record-breaking hot hot day I think
of the year yeah yeah it's very hot here
as well at least ur where I'm staying so
and it's your birthday happy birthday
for i hope everyone on YouTube which is
your happy birthday you know just
explain ok thanks i already had a nicer
nicer dinner and what someone was ready
not to do this short video it's not such
a such an exhausting game 2-2 to do a
trio so yeah and i will also return now
to my work
here to enjoy some of the weather so
thanks for watching and yeah I guess we
all will be on again on Saturday to do
game 11 right yeah okay okay thanks so
much everyone comments or questions on
YouTube and so much yeah thanks bye